Це відео шокувало мільйони турків.
На ньому задокументовані події під час
конституційного референдуму минулого року.
Десятки бюлетенів проштамповують постфактум,
аби надати їм чинності.
БАну Вардар та її колега все ще не можуть стримати люті,
коли переглядають кадри маніпуляцій і уявляють собі,
що цьогоріч те саме може статися знову.
Це відео - одна з причин, чому багато хто вважає,
що на виборах будуть маніпуляції.
Я не вірю, що референдум минулого року дійсно мав
результат на користь уряду.
Тож нині ми намагаємося самі подбати про те,
щоб не було обману.
"Здрастуйте, ми шукаємо спостерігачів на вибори – приєднуйтеся!
Майже щодня Бану та її колеги виходять на вулиці Стамбула.
Вони намагаються заговорити з перехожими та переконати їх
зареєструватися спостерігачами на вибори.
"Ми не з політичної партії, ми - громадська ініціатива…"
У Туреччині під час усіх голосувань на виборчих дільницях
дозволена присутність спостерігачів,
однак бажаючих часто бракує.
Бану прагне змінити це.
Утім, у цьому консервативно налаштованому кварталі Стамбула,
де живуть переважно прихильники Ердогана, їй не дуже щастить.
Найбільша опозиційна сила Туреччини,
Республіканська народна партія створила власний
центр реєстрації фальсифікацій на виборах.
Він організований краще, ніж волонтерська ініціатива Бану,
однак мета у них спільна - створення платформи
для координації спостерігачів та документування можливих випадків маніпуляцій.
Під час минулих виборів багато людей піддавали сумніву результати.
У багатьох було відчуття, що щось не так.
І це суспільне враження треба сприймати всерйоз.
Ми кажемо виборцям: віддайте свій голос, а потім
стежте за тим, що з ним відбувається.
Авні Езгюрель працює в проурядовій газеті Yeni Birlik.
Він впевнений, що опозиція та деякі ЗМІ перебільшують,
розповідаючи про маніпуляції на виборах.
За винятком кількох локальних порушень,
я не думаю, що у цій країні мають місце масштабні
маніпуляції на виборах.
Однак завжди знайдуться ті, хто хочуть все представити саме так.
Мовляв, бюлетені покрали, спалили чи знайшли в смітнику.
Щоразу таке заявляють.
Бану Вардар разом з однодумцям дивиться на це інакше.
Вони нарікають, що тема маніпуляцій під час
минулих виборів взагалі не була опрацьована.
Цього разу все має бути інакше,
а ще краще - взагалі не допустити фальсифікацій.
У цьому їхнє покликання.